[Musica]
la mia prima volta è stata traumatica
no non sto parlando di quello ma di
quando mi chiesero di stamparlo
stamparlo tutto pagina per pagina riga
per riga e non fu nemmeno l'ultimo
richiesero addirittura anni dopo sto
parlando dei primi siti portali si
chiamavano perché erano porte sui mondi
virtuali del brand
dovevano essere wow
ma anche aderenti agli spot televisivi
dovevano essere veloci nel caricamento
ma anche pieni di animazioni flash
alla vigilia del go live del nuovo
portale che avevo costruito mi chiesero
di stamparlo tutto e appenderlo sulle
pareti dell'ufficio ma perché io non
capivo perché chi doveva valutare
qualcosa di digitale
adottava i criteri dell'off line
adottava la carta stampata
poi lo capii perché la carta stampata e
criteri tradizionali
erano rassicuranti
il web faceva paura
faceva paura perché era aperto perché
era veloce perché non era lineare e
perché occorreva esserne competenti
faceva tremare tantissime poltrone di
persone che erano abituate a un giudizio
di pancia a un allenamento del senso
estetico ma che di html seo user
experience non sapevano nulla
allora 13 anni fa quando ho iniziato a
lavorare
il web ancora non vendeva era un
playground un parco giochi l'importante
era esserci in qualche modo e questo fu
la mia fortuna ma anche il mio costante
struggimento fortuna perché potevo
provare potevo sbagliare e non è forse
quella della cultura dell'errore quello
che insegnano le moderne start up quello
che promuovono oggi
però c'era anche il costante e
struggente vento perché la fama gli
onori e la brand equity sembravano
dipendere tutti dei mezzi tradizionali
televisioni in primis poi i blogger
iniziarono a dire la loro in quel
momento e lavoravo in un noto brand
automotive e nelle riunioni si diceva
non vogliamo che il nostro brand sia
percepito come chiuso
autoriferito ma cosa dobbiamo dire a
questi blogger io sorridevo perché mi
veniva in mente la famosa battuta
aborigeno ma io e te cosa ci dobbiamo
dire
ma che soddisfazione quando riuscì a
lanciare per la prima volta un modello
d'auto prima con i blogger
rispetto ai giornalisti della sacra
carta stampata un'eresia ma un grande
successo e da lì il dialogo sia primi
poi arrivò il momento della
colonizzazione
comprare un isola su second life per
farci cosa
non importa non si sa ma che figo dire
di averla
onestamente usai quel trend per far
capire che era importante esserci dove
il target passava al tempo anche oggi i
brand aprono i profili dove il loro
target passa del tempo tik tok instagram
facebook eccetera eccetera
quindi basta creare solo fortini e
pagare per avere un traffico in entrata
ma andare noi a colonizzare dove il
target passa al tempo
poi ci fu l'era dell'interazione perché
non portiamo il configuratore
dell'automotive fatto sul sito anche nei
concessionari nei punti fisici ottimo
facciamolo ma la sfida fu e quando il
concessionario è chiuso
e allora la mia mente creativa elaborò
un concessionario che avesse una vetrina
esterna con un touch screen dove le
persone potevano configurare l'auto
motiva anche quando il concessionario
era chiuso
poi scoppio facebook il boom di facebook
tutti dovevano avere un profilo e ci si
combatteva a suon di like e di fan
occhio a non comprarli perchè se no era
tutto un fake in quel momento e lavoravo
per un noto brand
sportivo di abbigliamento sportivo e mi
venne l'idea di utilizzare i calciatori
che sponsorizzava mo come chiave per
entrare in facebook ovvero loro erano
timorosi che cos'è facebook perché mi
deve servire e noi volevamo promuovere i
prodotti in modo autentico in modo
naturale in modo spontaneo e quindi
unimmo queste due cose con un approccio
win win in modo da aprire i profili dei
calciatori per farli conoscere come
persone oltre che come i personaggi ma
per inserire anche all'interno delle
loro vite i nostri prodotti nel modo più
autentico e naturale possibile
fu una grande soddisfazione vedere con
un piccolo video di unboxing di un nuovo
paio di scarpe fece diventare il brand
per cui stavo lavorando il più visitato
il più amato su facebook in italia in
quel momento
io ero una piccola campagnola creativa
adoravo il digital speravo veramente
diventasse qualcosa di più di una
passione per nerd
e in quel momento iniziai a vedere che
ci si poteva anche sbizzarrire e
divertire nel digital marketing
e poi scoppiarono i primi investimenti
nelle commerce
certo senza pretese in quel momento però
era un modo per dimostrare che non si
era proprio ignoranti nel mondo digitale
no e quindi iniziarono a esserci anche
le prime scelte coraggiose le campagne
solo digitali più soldi alla televisione
no più soldi nel digital e quindi le
prime trasformazioni in azienda le prime
figure specialiste si parlava di cro
conversion reit optimisation
io non ero più piccola avevo alle spalle
12 anni di lavoro e tre aziende e allora
pensavo fosse arrivato il momento di
sognare più in grande
basta solcare strade tracciate da altri
e in quel momento osservavo veramente
con curiosità quello che alcune startup
stavano facendo così veloci così agili
così innovativi e modelli di business
diversi
certo un conto era a essere angri
foolish incontro era lavorare per
grossissime aziende super strutturate
multinazionali che avevano nomi
altisonanti ma anche tantissima paura di
rovinare la propria reputerà
però inizia accarezzare l'idea di
portare l'esperienza la vitalità
l'agilità di una startup dentro un
contesto multinazionale con una grossa
organizzazione
e quindi dopo due anni di intenso lavoro
e studio e grazie all'aiuto di un team
cross funzionale meraviglioso a novembre
del 2020 riuscì a portare alla luce un
progetto inedito dedicato a te si chiama
è un e commerce ma non è un ecommerce
normale perché è una fusione
dell'efficienza del canale digitale
dell'e commerce con l'emozione che solo
dei prodotti creati con le persone
possono dare come funziona e
semplicissimo
si vasto dedicato a te e si può
personalizzare una confezione di
biscotti
semplicemente inserendo nomi dediche
foto ricordi e acquistando digitalmente
quello che si è personalizzato quindi un
prodotto unico che non esiste a scaffale
che è fatto proprio per te che lo stai
personalizzando in questo momento quindi
la e di ecommerce non era più commercio
elettronico per noi è diventato e di e
motional commerce un e commerce basato
sulle emozioni
e stato meraviglioso quando ho portato
la prima scatola di biscotti
personalizzata con una sua foto è una
dedica a mia nonna di 99 anni è stata la
prima volta in cui ha capito il mio
lavoro
non so se questo è il 3.0 il 4.0 e 5.0
non importa per me è solo uno dei tanti
inizi
e onestamente sono un po scettica e
rifuggo da chi dice che c'è una ricetta
unica un modo unico di fare le cose non
è vero ogni contesto ogni brand ogni
storia è diverso ma non penso neanche
che le 4 p del marketing siano andate in
pensione valgono ancora oggi io però li
ho sempre affiancate alle mie quattro
personali ci
coraggio creatività
ma soprattutto cuore e curiosità
e sono queste quattro componenti che mi
hanno accompagnato da quando ho iniziato
la mia carriera professionale ad oggi
che ho scoperto di essere malata
una malattia particolare si chiama neo
filia
è la voglia alla ricerca spasmodica e
continuativa del qualcosa di nuovo e
strano a definire la malattia perché la
desinenza figlia richiama qualcosa di
assolutamente positivo ma la neo filia
può portare a dipendenze a frustrazioni
e quindi va allenata come boe preferendo
la curiosità la comodità allenanti gusti
perché non sono scolpiti nella pietra né
quelli musicali né quelli legati al cibo
nessun gusto perché si cambia e
soprattutto prendendo le decisioni non
in modo affrettato ma dopo belle sedute
di respirazione o sonni sereni
come diceva il grande psicologo
americano caro lizard se questa neo
filia viene allenata essere sana ed
equilibrata può scatenare le due
emozioni positive per eccellenza
dell'essere umano
la gioia è l'interesse
parlare di contagio oggi è pericoloso ma
io spero vivamente che la mia neo figlia
sia super contagiosa grazie
[Applauso]